When my friend Jack was 22 he got a job on a small newspaper in Bend, Oregon. Basically he just talked his way into his job through sheer force of personality. He knew nothing about journalism, or what you're supposed to do in writing a newspaper story. One of his first assignments was a local school budget meeting.
当我的朋友杰克22岁时，他在俄勒冈州本德市的一家小报社找到了一份工作。基本上，他是靠着纯粹的个人魅力说服了对方，才得到了这份工作。他对新闻业一无所知，也不懂写报纸报道该做些什么。他的第一个任务之一是去报道当地的学校预算会议。
Everybody else's story was 350 words, 600 words. Mine was 7,000 words. I had just written every word that had occurred at this budget meeting, which was eight hours long.
别人的报道都是350字或600字，而我的有7000字。我只是把预算会议上发生的每一个字都记了下来，而那个会议开了八个小时。
Like in chronological order.
就像按时间顺序那样。
In chronological order. The meeting began at 9:00 AM. The first issue was how many No. 2 lead pencils to buy from Portland, and could we get a deal from Salem instead?
按时间顺序。会议于上午9点开始。第一个议题是该从波特兰购买多少支2号铅笔，以及我们能否从塞勒姆那边谈到一个更好的折扣？
Months pass. Jack gets better at this job, has friends in the newsroom. There are people younger and greener getting hired, which might think they're a little better, and he feels like he's getting the hang of things. He gets what seems like a very nice bonus.
几个月过去了。杰克在工作中表现得越来越好，在新闻编辑室也有了朋友。公司雇佣了一些更年轻、经验更少的人，他们可能觉得自己比杰克更强，而他觉得自己也逐渐掌握了门道。他得到了一个看起来非常丰厚的奖金。
Now this paper, the Bend Bulletin, was owned by a guy named Robert Chandler. Jack remembers him wearing a 10-gallon hat to work and smacking young reporters in the head with Strunk & White if they made grammatical errors. Chandler had installed, long before many big city newspapers had them, a computer network in the newsroom. This is 1980. Personal computers, word processing, passwords, all this stuff was all brand new.
这家报纸，《本德公报》，是由一个名叫罗伯特·钱德勒的人拥有的。杰克记得他戴着一顶夸张的宽檐帽上班，如果年轻记者犯了语法错误，他会用《斯特伦克与怀特》写作指南敲他们的头。早在许多大城市的报纸之前，钱德勒就在新闻编辑室安装了电脑网络。那可是1980年。个人电脑、文字处理、密码，所有这些东西当时都是全新的。
One late afternoon, it was an afternoon paper, so after closing everybody fled pretty much. I was sitting there by myself, and I was just fooling around with the computer. I typed in Mr. Chandler's name.
那是一个深夜，因为那是晚报，所以下班后大家都走得差不多了。我一个人坐在那儿，正摆弄着电脑。我输入了钱德勒先生的名字。
You mean you typed it in as the user name?
你是说你把它当成用户名输入了？
Yeah, as the user name. I was just guessing. What would be a password that Robert Chandler might use? I had been out to his house I guess the week or two before, and I had met his grandson. I don't remember what his name was, but let's just say it's Sam. So I typed in "Sam" for the password, and bling, all of a sudden his account opened up. I had access to everything in the entire computer system.
对，作为用户名。我只是在猜。罗伯特·钱德勒会用什么密码呢？我想大概是一两周前我去过他家，见过他的孙子。我不记得他叫什么名字了，但我们就假设是萨姆吧。所以我输入了“萨姆”作为密码，叮的一声，他的账户突然打开了。我可以访问整个电脑系统里的所有内容。
The managing editor at the time was a guy named Vic Roddick. I went into his file, and there were all the bonuses. I made, I can't remember, but I think it was like $7,800 a year, and he had given me like a $400 bonus. I saw everybody's bonus, and I saw everybody's annual paycheck, and I was at the bottom of the list. I was doing the worst of everybody in the room. I was flattened.
当时的执行主编是一个叫维克·罗迪克的人。我进入了他的文件夹，里面全是奖金信息。我不记得确切数字了，但我一年大概挣7800美元，而他只给了我400美元的奖金。我看到了所有人的奖金，看到了所有人的年度工资单，而我在名单的最底层。我是全办公室表现最差的。我感觉整个人都垮了。
Because you looked around the newsroom and you just thought, "These are my peers."
因为你环顾四周，心想：“这些人都是我的同行。”
Not only my peers, but there were some of them that I thought were worse than I was. I had to come to terms with the fact that I wasn't their equal. I was bad. I was really bad at what I was trying to do. It meant I suddenly had these weird resentments of my colleagues.
不仅是同行，我还觉得其中一些人比我还要差。我不得不接受这样一个事实：我并不如他们。我很差劲。我对自己所做的事真的非常不在行。这意味着我突然对同事产生了一种奇怪的怨恨。
Part of what's horrifying about finding out information that you're not supposed to know is that it actually robs you of your own kind of self-deception, your own fiction that you're actually doing OK.
发现那些你不该知道的信息最可怕的部分在于，它实际上剥夺了你自我欺骗的能力，剥夺了你那种“我其实做得还可以”的虚构幻想。
What's so crazy about this whole painful story is that he didn't go into the computer system hoping to actually find anything out. It just seemed like it would be sort of fun to snoop around. Spying for spying's sake.
这个痛苦故事最疯狂的地方在于，他进入电脑系统时并没有指望真的找到什么。他只是觉得窥探一下可能会很有趣。为了窥探而窥探。
Oh, I was-- yeah, it just felt thrilling. I just wanted to see if I could get inside. I didn't have any idea. I didn't have any motive for going into his file. There was nothing I was even looking for. I mean, it is the hacker's impulse. I've hung out with hackers, and one of the strangest things about them is that they often, once they get in, they have nothing to do. I was there when they would hack into the very depths of AT&T's telephone computers. And we'd get in, and they'd say, "OK, here we are, we're in." And I'm like, well what do we do now? Well, we're in.
哦，我当时——对，感觉太刺激了。我只是想看看自己能不能进去。我没有任何想法。我进入他的文件夹没有任何动机。我甚至没有在找任何东西。我的意思是，这就是黑客的冲动。我和黑客混在一起过，关于他们最奇怪的事情之一就是，一旦他们进去了，他们往往就没事可做了。我曾在那儿看着他们侵入美国电话电报公司（AT&T）的电话电脑系统深处。我们进去了，他们说：“好了，我们进来了。”然后我就问，好吧，现在我们要干嘛？哦，我们进来了。
We can make a phone call for free.
我们可以免费打个电话。
You know what we ended up doing? We ended up like giving my phone in New York three-way calling for free. That was what we ended up doing.
你知道我们最后做了什么吗？我们最后居然给我在纽约的电话弄了个免费的三方通话功能。我们最后就干了这个。
You hear a lot about professional spies. There's an entire genre of fiction and film and TV shows devoted to these people. Plus, the last few years spies are constantly in the news. The ongoing debate over how well the CIA does its job figuring out threats to our country.
你经常听说职业间谍。有一整类虚构文学、电影和电视节目专门讲述这些人。此外，过去几年间谍总是在新闻里出现。关于中央情报局在查明国家威胁方面做得如何的辩论一直持续不断。
But today on this program, we devote an hour to those who have been overlooked. The amateurs, people like you and me spying on coworkers and neighbors and sometimes complete strangers. As in Jack's case, not knowing what the hell they're doing. They are playing with fire.
但今天在这个节目中，我们要用一小时的时间谈谈那些被忽视的人。业余爱好者，像你我这样窥探同事、邻居，有时甚至是完全陌生人的人。就像杰克的情况一样，他们根本不知道自己在干什么。他们在玩火。
WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ芝加哥电台。这里是《这个美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our program today in four acts. Act One, The Lobbyist. A man discovers a secret channel on his cable service, and finds he cannot stop watching. Act Two, Life with the Haters, in which a mom with a new baby succumbs to the temptation to use her baby monitor for purposes it was not intended for. Act Three, Mystery Shoppers. In that act, ordinary people going undercover in coffee shops and chain stores. Act Four, Stop Bugging Me. In that act, counter-espionage in the suburbs. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，说客。一名男子在他的有线电视服务中发现了一个秘密频道，发现自己停不下来。第二幕，与讨厌鬼的生活，一位刚生完孩子的母亲抵挡不住诱惑，将婴儿监视器用于非预定用途。第三幕，神秘顾客。在这一幕中，普通人潜入咖啡店和连锁店。第四幕，别烦我。在这一幕中，郊区的反间谍活动。敬请收听。
Act One, The Lobbyist. This story comes from one of our contributing editors, Jonathan Goldstein. He's now the host of a program on the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation called Wiretap, where the stories are sometimes fully true, sometimes partly true, sometimes entirely untrue. This is from that program.
第一幕，说客。这个故事来自我们的特约编辑乔纳森·戈德斯坦。他现在是加拿大广播公司一档名为《窃听》节目的主持人，故事有时完全真实，有时半真半假，有时完全虚构。这是来自该节目的内容。
I guess it was back in February, and I had just installed a new VCR. When you set up a new VCR you have to put in the new channels, and there's an auto selection. So I press auto, and it's just whipping through channel two, three, four, five, six. And it goes way up the band.
我想那是在二月，我刚安装了一台新的录像机。当你设置新录像机时，你必须输入新频道，它有一个自动选择功能。所以我按下自动键，它就开始飞速切换频道：2、3、4、5、6。然后频率一直往上跳。
The numbers are going higher, and higher, and higher, and higher, trying to find a station. And it locks in to this station, and I'm looking at it. I'm going, "This is really bizarre. I think I'm looking at a lobby in an apartment building." The image wasn't great. There's no audio track. It's just a silent-- it's a security camera, I guess.
数字越来越高，为了搜寻频道。然后它锁定了这个台，我看着它。我想，“这太诡异了。我想我是在看一栋公寓大楼的大厅。”图像质量不怎么样。没有音频。它只是一个静音的——我想是个监控摄像头。
But you don't live in a building that has a lobby, right?
但你住的楼里没有大厅，对吧？
Right. Right.
对，没错。
So you're getting reception of a lobby that is not your own?
所以你收到的是不属于你的大厅的信号？
Right. Right. I mean, if I was living in a high rise, I wouldn't have been surprised to see my own lobby. It's a lobby in another part of the city, or in my town, or wherever.
对，没错。我的意思是，如果我住在高层公寓里，看到我自己的大厅我不会觉得惊讶。这是一个位于城里其他地方，或者我镇上，或者随便哪儿的大厅。
But you don't know where?
但你不知道在哪里？
Not a clue. Not a clue.
完全没头绪。一点头绪都没有。
I have this neighbor downstairs, and he's got 155 stations. He's got a satellite dish, and he's always bragging about how clear the reception is, and all these great channels. He can get like David Letterman on LA Times, so his life's great. And so just as a joke, I said, "Yeah, but do you get the lobby channel?" And I start explaining about this lobby that I'm getting on channel seventy-something. He says, "No," but that he would scan through and see if he indeed got it. But of course he didn't.
我楼下有个邻居，他有155个频道。他有个卫星天线，总是吹嘘接收效果有多清晰，还有这么多好频道。他能在《洛杉矶时报》上看大卫·莱特曼秀，所以他的生活很棒。所以我就开玩笑说：“是啊，那你收到大厅频道了吗？”我开始跟他解释我在七十几频道收到的这个大厅。他说：“没有，”但他会扫描一下看看他是否真的能收到。但当然他没收到。
I think there's a certain point, I think it's in March, where they start running a lot of re-runs. There's basically only about five shows that I watch religiously each week. Just out of habit, after walking the dogs or whatever and coming back at 9:30, I automatically go to those shows. Of course, they are re-runs. And then sort of thought, "Oh, I've always got the lobby to look at." I decided to just program it, keep it programmed on my dial.
我想在某一点，大概是三月份，他们开始播很多重播节目了。我每周雷打不动地看的节目其实也就五个左右。出于习惯，遛狗回来之后或者随便干点什么，9点半的时候我会自动去看那些节目。当然，都是重播。然后我就想，“哦，反正我还有大厅可以看。”我决定把它编进程序，保留在我的拨号盘上。
On the speed dial.
在快速拨号上。
So just as you're flipping from NBC to CBS to FOX, you have the lobby right alongside of them.
所以当你从NBC切到CBS再切到FOX时，大厅频道就在其中。
Yeah. Yeah, it's in the lineup.
对，没错。它就在列表里。
In the winter-- I'm not a jock, but what I like to do when it's really cold on the weekends is a watch golf, because when I watch golf, everybody's in a balmy part of the world, and the sun's shining. But at a certain point it just becomes tedious, and I thought, "Well, I'll see what's going on in the lobby."
在冬天——我不怎么运动，但我喜欢在周末天很冷的时候看高尔夫球赛，因为当我看着高尔夫时，每个人都在气候宜人的地方，阳光普照。但在某一点，这变得很乏味，我就想，“好吧，去看看大厅里在发生什么。”
So I go back and forth from golf to lobby, and to be honest, after not very much time, the lobby won. It was far more interesting, even though there was nothing going on. Then I thought, "Unfortunately, I have to go to work on Monday. I wonder what happens at key hours in the lobby? For instance, is there a rush hour in the lobby, like from 7 o'clock in the morning, or 6 o'clock in the morning, or at the end of the day? So I thought, "Well, you know what? I'll just start taping it."
所以我来回在高尔夫和大厅之间切换，说实话，没过多久，大厅就赢了。它有趣得多，尽管里面什么也没发生。然后我心想，“不幸的是，周一我要去上班。我想知道大厅在关键时刻会发生什么？例如，大厅里有早高峰吗，比如早上7点，或者早上6点，或者一天结束时？”所以我心想，“好吧，你知道吗？我开始录下来。”
You started taping it?
你开始录它了？
Yeah, I start setting up my VCR to record the lobby at peak hours, and see if there was any traffic. See if anybody was using the lobby.
对，我开始设置录像机，在高峰时段录制大厅，看看有没有人流。看看有没有人在用那个大厅。
So at this point how many tapes have you amassed?
那么到目前为止你攒了多少盘录像带了？
I guess only three. I had LP, so I've got like about six, seven hours of footage.
我想只有三盘。我用的是长时录制，所以我大概有六七个小时的录像。
On each one.
每一盘都有。
Yeah.
对。
So that's like 18 hours.
那大约是18个小时。
Yeah, something like that. And then I figured, why not, I can just fast forward through it. The first time I was watching, I was thinking like, is someone going to come walking in? That would have been the highlight. That was my goal. But no one ever walked in.
对，差不多。然后我想，为什么不呢，我可以快进看。第一次看的时候，我还在想，会不会有人走进来？那将是高光时刻。那是我的目标。但从来没有人走进来。
So I'm fast forwarding through it, and all of a sudden I see something. There's an image of a woman standing right in the center of the lobby, boom. And it looked as though she was wearing a pillbox hat, which caught my attention. I was on to something. I wasn't clearly wasting my time.
所以我快进着看，突然我看到了东西。画面里有个女人正站在大厅中央，砰。她好像戴着一顶药盒帽，这引起了我的注意。我发现了点名堂。我显然没有在浪费时间。
So all of a sudden there she is. There's this person standing in the middle of the lobby. And I sort of forget that I'm actually watching someone in the lobby, because I'm just so surprised to see anything at all. Sure enough, she starts going through her purse. She starts fumbling, she bends down, she stands up, and she looked in her hand. I assume she found her keys. She stops, she pauses, and then she just walks out of the frame.
于是突然间她就在那儿了。那个人正站在大厅中央。我有点忘了我其实是在盯着大厅里的人看，因为看到任何东西都让我太惊讶了。果然，她开始翻她的钱包。她开始摸索，弯下腰，站起来，看着手里。我猜她找到了钥匙。她停顿了一下，然后就走出了画面。
And goes in.
然后进去了。
I guess she goes in, yeah.
我想她是进去了。
Every time I fast forward through these tapes to see what else is going on in the lobby, if I do see a person, it's her. And she's always wearing this pillbox hat, or what seems to be a pillbox hat.
每次我快进这些录像带看大厅里还有什么动静时，如果我确实看到有人，那就是她。她总是戴着那顶药盒帽，或者看起来像是药盒帽的东西。
It's interesting because she seems to fumble. She doesn't always lose her keys, but like she'll walk. She'll be standing there, and she'll sort of like seem to trip on something and grab for balance.
这很有趣，因为她好像总是在摸索。她并不总是丢钥匙，但就像她会走。她会站在那儿，然后好像被什么东西绊了一下，去抓平衡。
But she's sort of fumbly?
但她有点笨手笨脚的？
Yeah, she's a fumbly person. But her hat stays on her head, so that's OK.
对，她是个笨手笨脚的人。但她的帽子一直戴在头上，所以还好。
I would be home, and I'd start preparing dinner. I'd look up, and I'd see the clock. It would be like 5 o'clock. Instead of like running into the kitchen, I would just like turn on the TV set and see if I could catch a glimpse of her live. Bingo, there she was.
我回家时，会开始准备晚餐。我会抬头看时钟。大概是5点钟。我没有冲进厨房，而是打开电视机，看看能不能捕捉到她生活的片段。宾果，她就在那儿。
Pillbox hat. About what time was this?
药盒帽。大概是什么时候？
Same time. Same time, like somewhere around the dinner hour. Yeah, and I thought this is like a little weird. Weird that I'm actually stopping what I'm doing to see if a person who I don't know is coming into a building.
同一时间。同一时间，大概在晚餐时间左右。对，我心想这有点奇怪。奇怪的是，我居然会放下手头的事去看看一个我不认识的人是否进入了一栋建筑。
On a daily basis.
每天都这样。
Yeah.
对。
How long have you been doing this?
你这么做多久了？
I guess about a month. I really didn't think anything of it. I mean, I have a full life. I work. I enjoy what I do. I have things to do. And yet for some reason, when you start watching someone, I don't know if you're fantasizing, or you just imagine what is this person all about? I guess I sort of figured she was like in her late 30s, maybe 40, had some sort of a regular job. It wasn't as though I was attracted to her like physically, but it was just someone else out there that I was getting to know via my TV set.
大概一个月吧。我真的没多想。我是说，我有完整的生活。我有工作。我很享受我的工作。我有事要做。但出于某种原因，当你开始观察某人时，我不知道你是陷入了幻想，还是你只是想象这个人到底是什么样的人？我想我大概认为她三十多岁，可能四十岁，有一份正经工作。并不是说我被她的身体所吸引，但这就是通过我的电视机认识的另一个人。
One night I'm watching, and she comes in with someone, and it really threw me for a loop. I thought, "Who is this person with?"
有一天晚上我在看，她和一个男人一起进来了，这真的让我大吃一惊。我心想，“这是谁啊？”
She came in with a man?
她和一个男人一起进来的？
Yeah. And there she is walking with this guy. I don't know if I was hurt. Then I thought, "This is ridiculous." I mean, this person has her own life. I'm just watching part of her life. I don't really know what's going on the rest of her time.
对。她就在那儿和那个家伙一起走着。我不知道我是不是受伤了。然后我心想，“这太荒唐了。”我的意思是，这个人有她自己的生活。我只是在看她生活的一部分。我并不真正了解她其他时间在干什么。
Anyways, it seemed as though there was a guy, and they seemed to be comfortable together.
总之，看起来确实有个男人，他们看起来很亲密。
How could you tell?
你怎么看出来的？
She was laughing,
她在笑。
Once I remember them coming in together. As usual she dropped her keys, or something comes out of her hand. She bent down to get them, and I thought, "How come he's not bending down and getting them for her?" I thought, "What kind of relationship is this?"
有一次我记得他们一起进来。像往常一样，她掉了钥匙，或者手里掉了什么东西。她弯下腰去捡，我心想，“他怎么不弯腰帮她捡呢？”我心想，“这是什么样的关系啊？”
One night after I watched the two of them come into the lobby, I thought, "Well, I wonder what's going to happen? I wonder if this guy is really going to stay around for a long time?" I kept the tape running just in case I'd miss something, but I went into the kitchen and made dinner. And I sat down in front of the TV and watched it.
有一天晚上，在看完他们两个走进大厅后，我想，“好吧，我倒要看看会发生什么？我想知道这个家伙会不会真的待很长时间？”我让录像带继续走，以免错过什么，但我走进厨房做了晚饭。然后我坐在电视机前看着它。
You watched while eating dinner?
你边吃晚饭边看？
I watched TV, the lobby. I was wondering if I would see this guy leave. He didn't leave.
我看电视，看大厅。我想知道能不能看到那个家伙离开。他没离开。
And how late did you end up watching until?
你最后看到多晚？
I watched until around midnight.
我一直看到午夜左右。
And he didn't leave?
他没走？
No. I watched it for about six hours. Put in another VHS tape, and I put it SLP, long speed. He never left.
没有。我看了大约六个小时。换了另一盘录像带，我设置了长时录制。他从来没离开。
He never came out?
他从来没出来过？
No. Hours and hours of tape, and I just sort of fast forwarded through it, but no, he never left. And I thought, "Good for her."
没有。好几个小时的录像，我就那么快进看着，但他真的从来没离开。我心想，“真为她高兴。”
And that's it? Just "good for her?"
就这样？只是“真为她高兴”？
Yeah.
对。
Nothing else?
没别的了？
No.
没有。
Not a little something else?
没什么别的内幕吗？
Mmm. I was like now growing-- I was becoming concerned for her happiness. But it's over. Whatever it is, it's over. And so I thought, "OK." As the grand finale, I went over and I actually deleted that channel. So the lobby channel--
嗯。我现在——我开始关心她的幸福了。但结束了。不管那是什么，它结束了。所以我心想，“好吧。”作为大结局，我走过去，删掉了那个频道。所以大厅频道——
So now when you go from say PBS to FOX it just goes straight.
所以现在当你从PBS切到FOX时，它直接跳过去了。
Yeah, straight through.
对，直接跳过。
Straight through. No shots of the lobby-- nothing.
直接跳过。没有大厅的镜头——什么都没有。
No more lobby. No.
再也没有大厅了。没有。
It's gone.
它消失了。
It's over. Yeah. I wasn't disappointed, but it was just like, I don't know. It sort of signified the end of winter. Spring was coming, and it's time to move on.
结束了。对。我并不失望，但这就像，我不知道。它象征着冬天的结束。春天来了，是时候继续前进了。
Jonathan Goldstein talking with Burt Covit on the CBC program Wiretap. That story, just to be completely clear, was a work of fiction based on true events, rendered as radio interview.
以上是乔纳森·戈德斯坦与伯特·科维特在CBC节目《窃听》中的对话。那个故事，为了完全澄清，是基于真实事件的虚构作品，以广播采访的形式呈现。
[MUSIC - "TELEVISION" BY ROBYN HITCHCOCK]
[音乐 - 罗宾·希区柯克的《电视》]
Act Two, Life with the Haters. Beth Lisick has this story of spying that starts out innocently enough with a baby and a mom.
第二幕，与讨厌鬼的生活。贝丝·利西克带来了这个故事，关于一个孩子和一位母亲，从窥探开始，虽然初衷很单纯。
My baby is a terrible sleeper. Sometimes he wakes up 10 or 12 times a night. So I heard about this book called The No-Cry Sleep Solution, a title that my friend is now using for his Morrissey cover band.
我的孩子睡觉很困难。有时候他一晚上要醒来10到12次。所以我听说了一本叫《无泪睡眠法》的书，这个书名现在我朋友正用作他莫里西翻唱乐队的名字。
The book says to get a baby monitor, and at the first sign of any disruption, you're supposed to rush in and start petting the baby back to sleep. There's also an elaborate system of charts and graphs they want you to fill out to keep track of everything he ate that day, how long he napped, at what intervals he's waking up at night. So at this point almost a year after he was born, we're clearly feeling crazy enough from sleep deprivation to actually try this.
书上说要买个婴儿监视器，一旦有任何动静，你就要冲进去安抚孩子入睡。他们还有一套复杂的图表系统，要你记录他那天吃了什么、睡了多久、晚上什么时候醒的。所以在这孩子出生将近一年后，我们显然被睡眠不足折磨得够呛，决定尝试一下。
NIGHT ONE: after an hour of rocking him in the rocking chair, he finally passes out. I flip on the baby monitor and sit at my desk. The next thing I know, his crying is coming through the speaker. I've fallen asleep sitting up. I check the time and write it down in my binder. 8:06, 24 minutes after I put him down.
第一晚：在摇椅上哄了他一小时后，他终于睡着了。我打开婴儿监视器，坐在桌前。接下来我就听到扬声器里传来了他的哭声。我坐着睡着了。我看了眼时间，记在活页夹里。8点06分，离我放下他才24分钟。
Night three. I nearly jump off the couch when I hear it. At first static, and then the voice coming in like a walkie-talkie broadcasting in my living room. "Yeah, so if you want to come around and fire one up, you know where I'll be. I got two or three for you, a'ight?" It's a phone conversation. It only takes me a second to figure out that it's got to be my neighbor, who everybody calls Lil' Mo.
第三晚。当我听到声音时，我差点从沙发上跳起来。先是静电，然后是一个声音像对讲机一样在我客厅里广播。“是啊，所以如果你想过来抽一口，你知道我在哪儿。我这儿有两三个，懂吗？”这是一场电话谈话。我只花了一秒钟就确定这一定是我邻居，大家都叫他“小莫”。
So I dim the lights and peek through the curtains, and there he is pacing back and forth in front of my house. "Yeah, I'm outside the haters'," his voice on the baby monitor says. Man, I really wish he wouldn't call us that. He hangs up the phone, leans against my fence, and a few minutes later a car pulls up, and he gets in.
所以我调暗了灯光，透过窗帘看出去，他正站在我家门前踱步。“是啊，我就在讨厌鬼家外面，”他在婴儿监视器里的声音说道。天哪，我真希望他别叫我们讨厌鬼。他挂了电话，靠在我的围栏上，几分钟后一辆车开了过来，他上了车。
Four years ago I bought a house in a rundown East Bay neighborhood on the Oakland border. My block is always full of trash, empty forties and blunt wrappers littering the sidewalk. The border of the city is ideal for drug dealing, so there's a lot of that going on. Some low-key prostitution too, but that didn't bother me. I'd lived in rough areas before.
四年前，我在奥克兰边界的一个破败的东湾社区买了一栋房子。我的街区总是堆满垃圾，人行道上满是空的酒瓶和烟头。城市边缘非常适合毒品交易，所以这类事情很多。也有一些轻微的卖淫，但那没困扰我。我以前住过粗犷的地区。
What really freaked me out was moving somewhere residential, and having real neighbors. Mostly I was afraid of chit-chatting. After years in the city, I didn't know the etiquette. I didn't want to embark on a long-term relationship of waving and smiling and chit-chatting about clogged gutters and car break-ins. And it didn't help that I was a complete specter of gentrification on my block, the first lower-income white lady to move into a working class black neighborhood.
真正让我害怕的是搬到住宅区，有了真正的邻居。我主要是怕闲聊。在城市里住了几年后，我不懂礼节。我不想开始一段长期的挥手微笑、聊排水沟堵塞和汽车被砸的闲聊关系。而且我也确实是这个街区士绅化的象征，第一个搬进工人阶级黑人社区的低收入白人女性。
My first strategy was to be really, really nice to everyone. I actually convinced myself that this was a good plan. The first couple months in the house, I sort of went overboard with the niceness. Later I found out that my neighbors were making fun of me for engaging in animated conversations with crackheads and psychotic people, people they themselves never talked to. "Why is she letting Jimmy hustle her with that stolen Tivo?" they wondered. "How come she's talking so long to Crazy Delfine?"
我的第一个策略是对每个人都特别特别好。我甚至说服自己这是一个好计划。搬进房子的头几个月，我在热情上有点过头了。后来我发现，邻居们在嘲笑我，因为我竟然和瘾君子和疯子聊得火热，而那些人他们自己从来都不搭理。“她为什么让吉米用那个偷来的Tivo机占她便宜？”他们想。“她怎么跟那个疯子黛尔芬聊了那么久？”
I quickly changed strategies and decided it would be easier to ignore everyone. I kept it friendly with George, an older man who lived on one side of me, and with JoJo, the neighborhood gossip, who would come over while I was getting my groceries out of the car and give me the crime blotter, who got shot and why. But basically I started minding my own business again. I stop waving.
我很快改变了策略，决定无视每个人更容易。我保持和住在隔壁的年长男人乔治的友好关系，还有邻居里的“长舌妇”乔乔，当我从车里卸杂货时，她会过来给我提供犯罪简报，谁被枪击了，为什么。但基本上我又开始各扫门前雪了。我停止了挥手。
An old lady on the other side of me? Never spoke to her. Her name was Eunice. One time I got her mail by accident. Instead of running the letter over, I put it in my mail slot for the postman to deliver.
另一边的老太太？从没说过话。她叫尤妮斯。有一次我错拿了她的信。我没有跑过去送还，而是把它塞回信箱让邮递员派送。
The reason for this was that Eunice's grandson, Lil' Mo, hated us. He dealt weed, and was always sitting in his driveway or on his front steps, which would have been fine except that he was such a jerk. He'd harass women walking down the street, even if they were with their kids, calling them whores. He'd actually get up off his porch and follow them down the street, yelling at them as they ran away, tugging on their kids' arms to hurry up.
原因是因为尤妮斯的孙子小莫讨厌我们。他卖大麻，总是坐在车道上或前台阶上，如果他不是那么混蛋的话，这也没什么。他会骚扰街上走路的女性，即使她们带着孩子，也叫她们妓女。他会真的从门廊上站起来，跟在她们后面沿着街道走，当她们跑开时对她们大喊大叫，拉扯着她们孩子的手臂催促她们快点。
The first time I walked by and said "Hi," he looked right at me and said, "Hater." He'd yell it at me in the middle of the day when I went to my car. He bragged about his Glock and his Uzis to everyone in the corner store, and I could tell a lot of people in the neighborhood were intimidated by him. I definitely was. So that's his voice that's showing up on my baby monitor.
我第一次走过并说“嗨”时，他看着我说：“讨厌鬼。”大白天我走向车库时，他也会对我喊。他在便利店里对所有人吹嘘他的格洛克手枪和乌兹冲锋枪，我知道社区里很多人都被他吓住了。我绝对是被吓住了。所以出现在我婴儿监视器里的就是他的声音。
Night four, I finally get the baby to fall asleep, and come out and turn on the monitor. I read for a while, and then peek out the curtains and see Lil' Mo sitting in his car in the driveway. Maybe he's on the phone. I get up and switch channels on the receiver to check in with him. Nothing.
第四晚，我终于让孩子睡着了，出来打开监视器。我读了一会儿书，然后透过窗帘往外看，看到小莫坐在车道的车里。也许他在打电话。我站起来切换接收器频道查看他在干什么。什么也没有。
The other day I got up the nerve to ask JoJo about him. She said that Lil' Mo doesn't even live in that house. He just comes over to deal out of his grandmother's yard. So my next door neighbor who hates me is not even my next door neighbor. That's when I start becoming slightly obsessed with him.
前几天我鼓起勇气问乔乔关于他的事。她说小莫根本不住那栋房子。他只是过来在他祖母的院子里交易。所以我隔壁那个讨厌我的邻居甚至都不是我真正的隔壁邻居。就在那时，我开始对他有点着迷了。
Day five, yes, I'm trying to listen during the day now. When my husband takes the baby out, I say that I'm going to take a nap, but then I see Lil' Mo and his friends in the driveway next door. Two of them are talking on their cell phone, so I run and switch on the monitor to see if I can get anything. Nothing. I switch channels. Nothing. I go back and forth trying to jar it into place.
第五天，是的，我现在试图在白天听。我丈夫带着孩子出去时，我说我要小睡一会儿，但我看到小莫和他的朋友在隔壁车道上。其中两个人在用手机说话，所以我跑过去切换监视器看能不能听到什么。什么也没有。我切换频道。什么也没有。我来回折腾试图锁定位置。
What's wrong with this thing? Why isn't it working? Maybe I should just get one of those police scanners that pick up everything, something reliable. Having heard him mention me that one time, I'm convinced that he's constantly talking crap about me.
这东西怎么了？为什么不工作？也许我应该买一个警察扫描仪来接收一切，那种可靠的东西。听到他那次提到我，我深信他一直在说我的坏话。
Night six, I'm watching a movie with the volume turned down so low that I have the subtitles playing on the DVD. The volume on the baby monitor, on the other hand, is turned all the way up. I hear static, and then I hear Lil' Mo start yelling at somebody, I think his girlfriend. His voice gets so loud that I turn off the monitor and just listen to it coming from outside the house.
第六晚，我正在看一部电影，音量调得很低，以至于DVD上都打着字幕。另一方面，婴儿监视器的音量调到了最大。我听到静电，然后听到小莫开始对某人吼叫，我想是他女朋友。他的声音大到我关掉监视器，直接听屋外传来的声音。
Night eight, all the lights in the house are out, and the baby's been asleep for a record three hours in a row. I'm laying on the couch dozing when his voice comes in. This time it's super clear. "I told you Antoine is going to drive her. You know I can't drive no more." As usual, I can only hear his side of the conversation. He's saying, "Teresa's picking her up," and, "She be doing it every day or some [BLEEP]," and then, "It's a liver, the liver and the bones."
第八晚，房子里的灯都关了，孩子已经连续睡了创纪录的三个小时。我正躺在沙发上打盹，他的声音传了进来。这次特别清晰。“我告诉你安托万会送她。你知道我不能再开车了。”像往常一样，我只能听到他那边的谈话。他说，“特蕾莎会去接她，”还有，“她每天都这么做或者随便什么鬼东西，”然后，“这是肝脏，肝脏和骨头。”
Somebody's sick. I figure he's talking about his grandmother Eunice, and I think, "Poor lady." She hardly ever comes out of her house. Whenever she does, there's always a big commotion. "Miss Eunice," people yell and wave. Even the teenage boys who are usually jerks are really nice.
有人生病了。我想他在说他祖母尤妮斯，我想，“可怜的老太太。”她几乎不出门。每次她出来，总是有大动静。“尤妮斯女士，”人们大喊并挥手。即使是平时混蛋的青少年也对她很好。
The first time I spoke to her, she came out on her back porch while I was in my back yard. She was wearing a flowered housecoat, and called out to me. When I said "hi" back, she laid into me for not pruning a huge fir tree whose branches were hanging into her yard. "It's blocking all the light in my house," she said, shaking her head. Then she got a little nicer and told me that the people who lived in my house in the '60s planted their Christmas tree one year, and it turned into that monster. I apologize about the overhanging branches, but the tree is over 25 feet tall, and I couldn't do it myself. I couldn't afford to pay someone, so I never did anything about it.
我第一次跟她说话时，她出来到后门廊，而我在我的后院。她穿着花睡袍，对我喊。当我回她说“嗨”时，她埋怨我不修剪那棵巨大的冷杉树，它的树枝垂到了她的院子里。“它挡住了我房子里所有的光线，”她摇着头说。然后她变得友善了一点，告诉我住在我房子的那些人60年代有年种了圣诞树，结果它变成了那个怪物。我为垂下的树枝道歉，但那棵树有25英尺高，我没法自己剪。我雇不起别人，所以我一直没管。
Day 10, there's a car idling in the driveway next door. One of Lil' Mo's friends, or maybe a relative, is in a green late '70s Cutlass that I've never seen before. There are six or seven people standing on the lawn looking up at the front door. Something's going on. I get myself outside and stand there, quite possibly for the third time ever watering my yard with a hose. I'm watering a pile of weeds.
第10天，隔壁车道上停着一辆车。小莫的一个朋友，或者可能是亲戚，坐在一辆我以前没见过的绿色70年代末的卡特拉斯轿车里。草坪上有六七个人在向上看着前门。有事发生了。我走出门站在那儿，很可能是第三次在给我的院子浇水。我是在浇一堆杂草。
Then Eunice comes out of the house. She's extremely frail, and is wearing a purple jogging suit. It takes her forever to get down the stairs. She finally reaches a car, and I hear her say to this total gangster guy over the booty bass thumping on the stereo, "Is this my chariot?" I look up, and she's smiling. She waves to me, and I smile and say "hi."
然后尤妮斯走出房子。她非常虚弱，穿着紫色的慢跑套装。她花了很长时间才下楼。她终于走到车前，我听到她对那个彻底的流氓家伙说，背景里还放着那种低音强劲的音乐，“这是我的战车吗？”我抬头看，她在微笑。她向我挥手，我微笑着说“嗨”。
After she drives away, I walk up to the fence and ask Lil' Mo, even though I know the answer, "Is that your grandmother?" He's nice to me, and tells me that she has cancer, and is going in for chemo. "She'll be all right," he says. And then, "We own this house, you know."
她开车走后，我走到围栏边问小莫，虽然我知道答案，“那是你祖母吗？”他对我很好，告诉我她得了癌症，要去化疗。“她会好起来的，”他说。然后，“这房子是我们家的，你知道吧。”
I go back inside and feel crappy about what a terrible neighbor I've been to this old lady. She's dying of cancer while I'm really busy training the jasmine plant to wind around the arbor. I could have trimmed that tree for her. I can't remember why I was so convinced that I couldn't deal with my neighbors in the first place.
我回到屋里，对自己作为这个老太太的邻居感到很糟糕。她正在死于癌症，而我却忙着修剪茉莉花以让它绕着凉亭长。我本可以帮她修剪那棵树的。我不记得当初为什么那么坚信自己无法处理好邻里关系。
I keep the monitor on all day. I'm hoping he'll say more about Eunice, but I just pick up two more drug deals. He gets a person to drive by, then they get in the car and go around the block. I've seen it a hundred times before, but I'm still compelled to go to the window and watch.
我整天开着监视器。我希望他能多说点关于尤妮斯的事，但我只听到了另外两次毒品交易。他找人开车经过，然后他们上车绕街区走了。我以前见过一百次了，但我还是忍不住走到窗前看着。
Day 12, I hear a car pull up next door, and look out the curtains. A young woman is helping Eunice up the stairs to her house. I make a batch of chicken soup, put it in a Tupperware, and spend most of the day trying to find the perfect time to bring it over, ideally when Lil' Mo is not out front, which is hardly ever. I have to admit, part of me hopes that if I bring her soup, maybe he'll stop calling me "hater." I try switching on the monitor to see if he's planning on going anywhere, but all I get is a bit of political poetry from the pirate radio station.
第12天，我听到一辆车在隔壁停下，从窗帘往外看。一个年轻女子正扶着尤妮斯上楼。我做了一份鸡汤，放进特百惠盒子里，花了一整天时间想找个完美的时间送过去，理想情况下是在小莫不在前面的时候，这几乎不可能。我必须承认，我的一部分想法是如果我给她送汤，也许他会停止叫我“讨厌鬼”。我试着打开监视器看他是否打算去哪儿，但我只听到海盗电台的一点政治诗。
I wait until he leaves his yard to go to the apartment building across the street before I walk over. Way too obvious. He sees me going up the stairs to their front door, and he runs back across the street, saying, "What do you want?" I tell him I'm just bringing soup to his grandma, and he lets me in. The house smells pretty terrible, like burned Twinkies and rotting vegetables.
我等到他离开院子去街对面那栋公寓楼后，才走过去。太明显了。他看到我上楼走向前门，就跑回街对面说：“你要干什么？”我告诉他我只是给奶奶送汤，他让我进去了。房子里闻起来很难闻，像烧焦的饼干和腐烂的蔬菜。
He leads me back to her bedroom, and pauses for a second and says, "What's your name?" I tell him, and he goes inside the room and says, "The lady from next door is here for you." He walks out, and I go in and find her sitting up in bed, watching a movie. Her bedroom door has a shoe rack hanging from it that is filled with videotapes, mostly comedies and musicals. I tell her I heard she was sick and brought her some soup. She's really sweet. She gets out of bed and tickles my son's chin, asking me questions about how old he is, what he's doing.
他带我走到她的卧室，停了一秒说：“你叫什么名字？”我说了，他走进房间说：“隔壁的女士来看你了。”他走出来，我走进去发现她坐在床上看电影。她的卧室门上挂着一个装满录像带的鞋架，大多是喜剧和音乐片。我告诉她我听说她病了，带了点汤。她真的很甜。她下床摸着我儿子的下巴，问我他多大，在干什么。
I follow her into the kitchen, where there's a big swarm of fruit flies and piles of dirty dishes. I think of all the time her grandson spends hanging out front when he could at least make sure her kitchen is clean. She takes the soup from me, and we chat a bit about the weather.
我跟着她走进厨房，那里有一大群果蝇和堆积如山的脏碗。我想起她孙子花那么多时间待在前面，至少本可以确保她的厨房是干净的。她接过我给的汤，我们聊了聊天气。
A couple days later, I'm out walking my kid in the stroller, and my neighbor Maynard from a couple doors down says "hi." We usually say "hi" to each other when he's out washing his car, but this time he turns down his stereo and throws his chamois over his shoulder. "Touch the cooler," he says, and points to a Styrofoam cooler on the ground. At least I think that's what he says. I'm not really sure what he wants me to do. Did he just say, "Touch the cooler?" I stand there for a second, and then he tells me that's what they say in New Orleans, where he's from. It means, "grab a beer." I really want to accept his offer, but its 10:00 in the morning.
几天后，我推着婴儿车走在街上，隔壁邻居梅纳德跟我说“嗨”。他洗车时我们通常会打招呼，但这次他关掉音响，把羊皮抹布搭在肩上。“摸那个冷柜，”他说，指着地上的聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料冷柜。至少我以为他是这么说的。我不太确定他想让我做什么。他刚才说的是“摸那个冷柜”吗？我站在那儿一秒钟，然后他告诉我那是他们新奥尔良（他家乡）人的说法。意思是，“拿瓶啤酒。”我真的很想接受他的提议，但这才是早上10点。
We talk for a bit, and I realize that he knows all of our names, when we go to work, the fact that we were gone for a few days last month. He knows we have feral cats living in our garage. He says Lydia from across the street told JoJo, and then JoJo told him that I brought Miss Eunice soup the other day. He wants to know what kind. I'm almost surprised he doesn't know already. So the neighbors are watching me as closely as I'm watching Lil' Mo.
我们聊了一会儿，我意识到他知道我们所有人的名字，我们什么时候去上班，知道我们上个月离开过几天。他知道我们车库里住着野猫。他说街对面的莉迪亚告诉了乔乔，乔乔又告诉了他我前几天给尤妮斯女士送汤的事。他想知道是什么汤。我甚至惊讶他不知道。所以邻居们也在像我观察小莫一样密切地观察着我。
Day 16, I bring Lil' Mo's grandmother food about four or five more times, but now I'm bolder, and will do it when he's sitting out front. I don't even bother to check the baby monitor before I walk outside. One time I brought a whole lasagna, because there seemed to be a lot more people hanging around the house lately. Mo followed me in, but then he stayed outside the door lurking for a bit. Eunice looked a lot sicker, really skinny. She joked that maybe my food would fatten her up. Mo leaned his head in and nodded to the lasagna on top of the dresser and said, "So what is that?" "Lasagna," I say. "Meat lasagna?" "Yeah, meat lasagna."
第16天，我又给小莫的祖母送了四五次食物，但这次我更大胆了，当他坐在前面时我也敢送。我在出门前甚至懒得检查婴儿监视器了。有一次我带了一整盘千层饼，因为最近房子周围似乎围着更多的人。莫跟着我进去了，但他待在门外徘徊了一会儿。尤妮斯看起来更虚弱了，真的瘦骨嶙峋。她开玩笑说也许我的食物能帮她长点肉。莫探进头，对着梳妆台上的千层饼点了点头说：“那是啥？”“千层饼，”我说。“肉千层饼？”“对，肉千层饼。”
He stopped calling me "hater" after that. It's not like we talk that much, but at least it's not uncomfortable anymore. Sometimes he just nods or gives me a "what's up" and then lets me in the house, and I've totally stopped trying to listen to his conversations.
那之后他不再叫我“讨厌鬼”了。并不是说我们聊得很多，但至少不再那么别扭了。有时他只是点头或跟我打个招呼，然后让我进屋，我也彻底停止了听他的谈话。
About a month after I first brought Eunice soup, she dies after getting two more blood transfusions. That day the whole street is crowded with people drinking and kids running around, and I go out and touch the cooler with Maynard and JoJo. He tells me if I don't want the gang kids sitting on my fence, I should just go up and tell them to please get off of it. So I do, and they're really cool about it, and they haven't sat on it since.
我第一次给尤妮斯送汤大约一个月后，她在又输了两次血后去世了。那天整条街挤满了喝酒的人和跑来跑去的孩子，我出去和梅纳德与乔乔一起摸了那个冷柜。他告诉我如果我不希望帮派里的孩子坐在我的围栏上，我应该直接走过去请他们下来。于是我这么做了，他们真的很客气，从那以后再也没坐过。
One day I hear the screeching of tires and a bunch of people yelling, and go to the front window. There are three unmarked cop cars and a van outside. Lil' Mo is there on the phone, and I run to switch on the baby monitor. Where is it? I can't find it. I call my husband's cell phone and ask where the monitor is. He says he put it in the storage closet because the baby's sleeping fine. He didn't think we really needed it anymore. I grab it, plug it in, and get a bunch of static from the police radios. Of course we need it.
有一天我听到轮胎摩擦地面的尖叫声和一群人的喊叫声，跑到前窗看。外面有三辆没标记的警车和一辆厢式车。小莫正在打电话，我跑过去打开婴儿监视器。在哪儿呢？我找不到。我给我丈夫的手机打电话问监视器在哪儿。他说他把它放进储藏室了，因为孩子睡得很好。他觉得我们不再需要它了。我抓过它，插上电，收到了一堆来自警察无线电的静电。我们当然需要它。
Beth Lisick is a writer in the Bay Area. Coming up, spies working for a monarch named Burger King and for a clown named Ronald. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
贝丝·利西克是湾区的作家。接下来，为名叫“汉堡王”的君主和名叫“罗纳德”的小丑工作的间谍。芝加哥公共电台和公共广播国际公司为您播出，节目稍后继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Spies Like Us. stories of amateur spies and the consequences of their spying. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act three.
这里是《这个美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目是“像我们一样的间谍”。讲述业余间谍的故事以及他们窥探的后果。现在进入节目的第三幕。第三幕。
There are companies that want amateurs to go into chain stores and fast food places, pretend to be regular customers, and then report in on how things are going there. The job title, mystery shoppers. A trade association says that there are now tens of thousands of people doing this job. Mostly it's freelance work. It's secretive, and they're not supposed to talk about it.
有些公司希望业余爱好者去连锁店和快餐店，假装成普通顾客，然后报告那里的情况。工作头衔是：神秘顾客。一个行业协会称，目前有成千上万的人在做这份工作。大多是自由职业。这是秘密进行的，他们被要求不能谈论。
When our producer, Lisa Pollak, went on to a mystery shoppers discussion board on the internet looking for interviewees, it kicked off this debate there about whether chain store employees might be listening right now to the radio to get tips about how they're being surveilled. Lisa was able to get a few mystery shoppers to talk with her, and to let her tag along as they spied.
当我们的制作人丽莎·波拉克在互联网上的神秘顾客讨论板上寻找采访对象时，它引发了一场关于连锁店员工现在是否可能正在收听电台以获取如何被监视的技巧的辩论。丽莎最终说服了几名神秘顾客与她交谈，并让她在他们进行间谍活动时跟随。
Pat's assignment tonight is pretty routine, a stake-out at a coffee shop. She won't let me follow her. She's afraid I'll blow her cover. But she's agreed to wear a wireless mic so I can listen in while she checks out the store.
帕特今晚的任务很常规，在咖啡店进行监视。她不让我跟随。她怕我暴露她的身份。但她同意戴上无线麦克风，这样我可以在她检查商店时监听。
We have walked in, and I'm looking. The first thing I see are three employees behind the counter. I see a merchandise display. Everything looks really well-stocked here. I'm looking at the floor, which does have a few pieces of paper on it. Took a quick look at the condiment table, which looks very clean and well-tended. And I'm kind of walking away because the customers in the store are looking at me talking to myself here.
我们走进去，我看着。我看到的第一件事是柜台后面的三名员工。我看到了商品展示。这里的一切看起来库存很足。我看着地板，上面确实有一些纸屑。快速看了一眼调味品台，看起来非常干净且维护得很好。我有点走开了，因为店里的顾客看着我自言自语。
I can't tell you the name of the coffee shop, or where it is, or the kind of drink that Pat's pretending to be interested in. I can only tell you that she's about to walk up to the counter to administer a test, to see if the woman behind the cash register is familiar enough with a drink to tell a customer what's in it.
我不能告诉你咖啡店的名字，或者它在哪里，或者帕特假装感兴趣的饮料种类。我只能告诉你，她正要走向柜台进行一次测试，看看收银台后的女人是否对饮料足够熟悉，能告诉顾客里面有什么。
Hi.
你好。
Can I help you?
我能帮您吗？
Well a friend of mine at work the other day had something called a [BLEEP]. What is that?
哦，我同事前几天喝了一种叫[消音]的东西。那是什么？
The clerk nails it. She knows all four ingredients. "It's really good," she tells Pat. "You should try it."
店员答对了。她知道所有四种成分。“真的很好喝，”她告诉帕特。“你应该试试。”
It does sound good, but I think I'll just have the latte.
听起来确实不错，但我还是只要拿铁吧。
Two minutes later, I know because she timed it, Pat carries the drink out to her van. She takes the lid off the cup and weighs it on a cooking scale. She gets out what looks like a small meat thermometer and drops in the coffee.
两分钟后，我知道是因为她计时了，帕特带着饮料走到了她的车里。她取下杯盖，用烹饪秤称了重量。她拿出看起来像个小型肉类温度计的东西，插进咖啡里。
While I'm waiting for the thermometer to register the temperature, I'm writing down the notes about the shop. I'm writing down the name of the employee who served me. She was wearing the correct uniform, but the jacket was over the uniform, and I will check later to find out whether that's regulation, because at this point I don't remember. But I'll check and make sure.
当我在等温度计显示温度时，我正在写关于这家店的笔记。我记下了服务我的员工的名字。她穿着正确的制服，但制服外面套着外套，我稍后会查询一下那是否符合规定，因为现在我不记得了。但我会核实并确认。
This assignment will take Pat about an hour. That includes the report she'll write when she gets home. For this she'll get about $5, plus reimbursement for the coffee. It's the freebies that attract a lot of mystery shoppers. Movie tickets, meals, a free night in a hotel, undercover of course.
这项任务帕特大约需要一小时。包括她回家后要写的报告。为此她能拿到大约5美元，外加咖啡费报销。是这些免费赠品吸引了许多神秘顾客。电影票、餐券、酒店免费过夜，当然是在潜伏期间。
She won't get rich this way, but Pat likes the work. She's a full-time mom who needs a little part-time income, something with flexible hours, close to home. She prefers the simpler assignments, convenience stores, casual restaurants, where she doesn't have to be too sneaky, or pretend she's someone she's not. One assignment she won't do, she says, requires the mystery shopper to go to a fast food restaurant and order two meals, inside and at a drive through, in one visit. Pat says it's a dead giveaway.
她靠这个发不了财，但帕特喜欢这份工作。她是全职妈妈，需要一点兼职收入，时间灵活，离家近。她更喜欢简单的任务，便利店、休闲餐厅，在那里她不需要太狡猾，或者假装成另一个人。她说有一项她不会做的任务，要求神秘顾客去一家快餐店点两顿餐，在一次访问中，一次在店内一次在免下车窗口。帕特说那绝对会暴露。
You know, they've seen you in the store looking around. They've watched you go into the bathroom, perhaps staring at the floor, which the average customer doesn't necessarily do. If they're overly friendly at the drive through window when you do that part of the shop, you know you've been made.
你知道，他们在店里看到你四处张望了。他们看着你去了洗手间，可能盯着地板看，普通顾客不一定会这样做。如果你在免下车窗口做那部分任务时表现得过于友好，你知道你已经被识破了。
Pat says if she gets made, if they figure out who she is and confront her, she won't get her money for the job. Mystery shoppers worry about this stuff. It's the kind of thing they discuss on their online message boards. In fact, there's an official mystery shoppers protocol for what to do if you get caught.
帕特说如果她被识破了，如果他们弄清她是谁并质问她，她就拿不到钱了。神秘顾客很担心这些事。这是他们在线留言板上讨论的内容。事实上，官方有一套针对如果被发现该怎么做的协议。
It's been very much emphasized that if you're ever approached and asked if you are a mystery shopper, it's drilled down, deny, deny, deny, deny.
重点强调过，如果你被靠近并问你是否是神秘顾客，一定要 drill down（深挖/坚持），否认，否认，否认，否认。
This is Lynn, or at least that's what she asked me to call her.
这是琳，或者至少她要求我这样称呼她。
You're supposed to ask the person, "What's that? What's a mystery shopper?" And other mystery shoppers that I've read about on the internet have said things like, "Mystery shopper? Is that something special? Did I win a prize?" I don't think I could pull off that kind of ignorant effectively.
你应该问那个人，“那是什么？什么是神秘顾客？”我在网上读到的其他神秘顾客说了一些像“神秘顾客？那是什么特别的东西吗？我是不是赢了大奖？”之类的话。我不认为我能有效地表现出那种无知。
Lynn considers mystery shopping less of a job than a hobby where she gets paid. Unlike Pat, she takes the jobs that require some performance skills. Once, while fake shopping for a mortgage, she invented a husband named Steve, a biologist with a terrible credit history. Another time she pretended to be a member of a fringe religious groups to see if a leasing agent would still rent to her.
琳认为神秘顾客比起工作，更像是一种有报酬的爱好。与帕特不同，她喜欢那些需要表演技巧的工作。有一次，在假装寻找抵押贷款时，她虚构了一个叫史蒂夫的丈夫，一个有糟糕信用记录的生物学家。另一次她假装成边缘宗教团体的成员，看看租赁代理是否还会把房子租给她。
I've gone into complete acting mode. I have pretended to be a graphic artist that is looking for a real estate space to rent. And I went in, and I had the appointment. When I got to the leasing office, they had one of those reader board signs that was welcoming my company. They had my company name, my fake company name. It was bizarre.
我进入了完全的表演模式。我假装成一个正在寻找办公地点的平面设计师。我进去了，有了预约。当我到达租赁办公室时，他们有一个欢迎我公司的告示牌。他们写上了我的公司名称，我的虚构公司名称。太离谱了。
And then I got really into character, and the woman at one point was talking about what kind of design work I do. I didn't have anything prepared for discussing what my visual style is, so I rolled up my shirt sleeve and showed her my tattoo, and told her it was an original design, and that that was representative of my work.
然后我完全进入了角色，那个女人一度在谈论我做哪种设计工作。我没有准备讨论我的视觉风格，所以我卷起衬衫袖子向她展示了我的纹身，并告诉她那是原创设计，代表了我的作品。
Aren't you sitting there feeling like, oh, this person must know I'm faking it. She must know I'm a mystery shopper. Are you worried about that?
你不坐在那儿想，哦，这个人一定知道我在撒谎。她一定知道我是神秘顾客。你不担心那个吗？
I don't worry about that. I worry that people think I'm an idiot. I had a shop where I had touch 1,250 pieces of clothing and not buy any of them, and not get noticed by any of the staff.
我不担心那个。我担心别人认为我是个白痴。我有一次任务要摸1250件衣服而不买其中任何一件，并且不能被任何员工注意到。
What?
什么？
1,250 pieces of clothing in a clothing store. I was checking to see if you've got something on a hanger, and the hangar says size eight, is that blouse really a size eight?
服装店里1250件衣服。我在检查挂衣架上的东西，挂牌上写着8号，那件衬衫真的就是8号吗？
It wasn't just literally that you had to touch them, you had to look to see if the size matched the hanger?
不仅仅是字面上你必须摸它们，你还得看尺寸是否与衣架相符？
I had to pull out the tags on all of those clothes. If they knew that I was a mystery shopper, they didn't say anything about it, but it's really hard to do that and not feel like they're not noticing that you're out there touching everything.
我必须把那所有衣服的标签拉出来。如果他们知道我是神秘顾客，他们什么也没说，但真的很难做到这一点而不感觉他们注意到了你在那里摸遍了一切。
Did you have a little story for yourself? Like oh, I have OCD or something if they asked you what exactly your problem was?
你有没有为自己编个小故事？比如哦，如果他们问你到底有什么毛病，你就说我有强迫症什么的？
Well I've used that in the past, but--
嗯，我过去用过那个，但——
You have?
你用过？
Well, yeah. But that explains like why I need to talk to everybody in the grocery store, or why I have to go to produce, and then why I have to go back to produce. I have to go to produce three times, and I'm not going to be satisfied until I talk to the produce guy. If people look at me a little askew, like your behavior seems odd, I'll just say to people, look, I have OCD, and just get really hostile.
嗯，对。但那可以解释为什么我需要在杂货店和每个人说话，或者为什么我必须去生鲜区，然后再回到生鲜区。我必须去生鲜区三次，我不和生鲜区的伙计说话绝不罢休。如果人们斜眼看我，觉得我的行为怪异，我就对人说，听着，我有强迫症，然后表现得非常敌对。
I asked Lynn if she thinks people get fired because of the reports she writes. She says she doesn't know, but she'd like to think they don't.
我问琳她是否认为人们会因为她写的报告而被解雇。她说她不知道，但她希望他们不会。
Later I call a mystery shoppers trade group, the Mystery Shopping Providers Association, which represents the companies who hire the shoppers. They say their Association discourages the use of mystery shopping for punishing or firing workers. It's a tool meant for training, they say, to help employees improve. Either way, Lynn has no qualms about doing it. She seems honestly surprised when I suggest there's something deceitful or unfair about watching strangers without their knowledge and then evaluating their work.
后来我给一个神秘顾客行业组织——神秘顾客供应商协会打了电话，该协会代表了雇佣这些顾客的公司。他们说他们的协会不鼓励使用神秘顾客进行惩罚或解雇员工。他们说这是一种用于培训的工具，旨在帮助员工改进。无论如何，琳对此毫无心理负担。当我建议在不知情的情况下监视陌生人然后评估他们的工作有某种欺骗性或不公平时，她似乎真的感到惊讶。
I don't feel like it's a lie or a deception. I feel like it's more akin to acting.
我不觉得这是谎言或欺骗。我觉得它更像是表演。
But it is a deception.
但它就是一种欺骗。
Well, yeah, OK, fair enough. Yeah, it is a deception. But it's in the service of something. I'm not doing this just to screw with you, because I think it is legitimate to evaluate people who work in the service industry on an objective basis.
嗯，对，好吧，公平地说。对，它是欺骗。但它是服务于某种目的的。我做这个不是为了整你，因为我认为在客观基础上评估服务行业的人员是合理的。
Other people get evaluated in their job, she says. Why not service workers? Why not salespeople at Target or McDonald's? And it's not like those workers don't know what's happening.
其他人也在工作中被评估，她说。为什么服务人员不行？为什么塔吉特或麦当劳的推销员不行？而且这些员工又不是不知道会发生什么。
Jack Elam works at a Starbucks in Chicago. He's the only person interviewed for this story who was willing to give his actual full name. He talked to This American Life's intern, Amy O'Leary. The minute she brought up mystery shoppers, he immediately launched into a list of everything they're looking for at Starbucks.
杰克·埃拉姆在芝加哥的一家星巴克工作。他是本篇故事中唯一愿意提供真实全名的采访对象。他向《这个美国生活》的实习生艾米·奥利里讲述了这一切。她一提到神秘顾客，他立刻列出了一份星巴克神秘顾客所要查看的一切列表。
You're graded on your speed of time. You're also graded on quality of service, temperature, dress codes, store appearance, and things like that. And then they grade you on it.
你的速度是有评分的。你还要在服务质量、温度、着装规范、店容店貌等方面得到评分。然后他们给你评分。
Don't you ever feel like you're being spied on though?
你不觉得被监视了吗？
Not really, no. I think that's good in a sense that it makes a lot of stores stay up to code, follow all the rules and regulations. Yeah, I don't see a problem with them. They can come visit anytime they want.
并不觉得，没有。我认为这在某种意义上是好的，因为它能让很多商店保持规范，遵守所有的规章制度。对，我不觉得他们有什么问题。他们随时可以来访问。
Jack's had other jobs like this, and he says it just comes with the territory. And sometimes he wonders about the mystery shopper when it gets really busy, or when there's an especially tough customer. What if it's them?
杰克做过其他类似的工作，他说这只是工作的一部分。有时候当店里特别忙，或者有一个特别难缠的顾客时，他会猜测那是神秘顾客吗？如果是他们呢？
It could be a 99-year-old lady come up and order something, and it could take her 45 minutes to pay for it because she's counting one penny at a time. That could be your mystery shopper. You never know.
可能是一位99岁的老太太走过来点东西，她可能要花45分钟来支付，因为她正在一个一个地数硬币。那可能是你的神秘顾客。你永远不知道。
So you have to be nice to everybody?
所以你必须对每个人都友善？
Yes. Yes. Like I said, you never can tell.
是的。是的。就像我说的，你永远猜不到。
Ever since I started work on this story, when I'm at any chain store, I'm acutely aware that all of the things being said to me come from a script. I mean, everybody already knows that, but seeing it from the mystery shopper's point of view was like going backstage and really seeing how things work. Here on a piece of paper were the questions the clerks were supposed to ask me, the number of minutes before I'm supposed to be greeted, the products they're supposed to promote.
自从我开始做这个故事，当我在任何连锁店时，我都会敏锐地意识到对我说的所有话都来自剧本。我是说，每个人都知道这一点，但从神秘顾客的角度看，就像走到后台真正看到事情是如何运作的。就在纸上，写着店员应该问我的问题，我被迎接前应经过的分钟数，他们应该推广的产品。
At this one electronics store, the mystery shopper I was with asked the sales girl about vacuum cleaners. On cue, she walked over to the exact model she was supposed to be pushing that day, and looking right at us in a completely sincere tone of voice, told us that she thought this vacuum was the one we really needed.
在那家电器商店，我跟随的神秘顾客问店员关于吸尘器的问题。收到信号后，她走到了那天她应该推销的那款完全相同的型号前，用完全真诚的语气看着我们说，她认为这个吸尘器才是我们真正需要的。
There's nothing evil or wrong about any of that. It just makes you feel weird. Lynn told me she'd had a similar feeling, but working as a mystery shopper made her realize what most jobs in most stores are really about.
这一切都没有邪恶或错误之处。只是让你感觉很怪。琳告诉我她有类似的感受，但做神秘顾客让她意识到大多数商店里的大多数工作到底是怎么回事。
You look at companies that pay these minimum wage jobs, and then they'll have a 16-page questionnaire asking, did this employee do this, this, this, and this, and it's an astonishing amount of behaviors to have to evaluate. They want to know if you smiled, if you presented this, did you offer the new veggie dog, did you do this, did you do that? I mean, if somebody goes up and says this is what I want, and you get it for them and give them their change, that's all they really need. And it's these people who make hardly any money, and the things that they have to do are ridiculous.
你看看那些支付最低工资的公司，然后他们会有一个16页的问卷，问这个员工是否做了这个、这个、这个，还有这个，评估的行为数量令人震惊。他们想知道你是否微笑了，你是否展示了这个，你是否提供了新的素食热狗，你做了这个吗，你做了那个吗？我的意思是，如果有人走过来，说这就是我想要的，你给他们拿过来并找零，那才是他们真正需要的。而正是这些人，几乎挣不到什么钱，却不得不做这些荒唐的事情。
Well, ridiculous if you're the person who has to smile and suggest veggie dogs 80 times a day. Not so ridiculous if you're the manager who needs to move veggie dogs. In the end, Lynn has a lot in common with the kid behind the counter. They're both working for big companies, trying to help those companies turn out a consistent product everywhere all the time. They're both making near minimum wage. One of them just happens to be watching the other.
好吧，如果你是那个每天必须微笑并建议80次素食热狗的人，那很荒唐。如果你是需要推销素食热狗的经理，那就不那么荒唐了。归根结底，琳和柜台后面的那个孩子有很多共同点。他们都在为大公司工作，试图帮助那些公司在任何地方、任何时候都能产出一致的产品。他们都拿着接近最低工资的薪水。只是其中一个人刚好在监视另一个人。
Lisa Pollak is one of the producers of our program.
丽莎·波拉克是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "TOWN WITH NO SECRETS" BY MARK MALLMAN]
[音乐 - 马克·马尔曼的《没有秘密的小镇》]
Act Four, Stop Bugging Me. It's almost a law of nature that wherever there's a spy, there's a counter-spy, somebody using counter-espionage techniques to catch somebody doing espionage. And so if you think that someone is spying on you in your home, you can actually hire somebody to help you with domestic counter-espionage. Jane Feltes visited one of their suburban outposts.
第四幕，别烦我。这几乎是一条自然法则，只要有间谍的地方，就有反间谍，有人在使用反间谍技术来抓捕从事间谍活动的人。所以如果你认为有人在你的家里监视你，你真的可以雇人帮你进行国内反间谍活动。简·费尔特斯拜访了他们的一个郊区据点。
A couple times a week someone calls the hotline at Special Solutions Inc., a counter-surveillance company in Des Plaines, Illinois, thinking that their place has been bugged. That's when Mark Amerazian springs into action and readies his equipment.
一周几次，有人会拨打特别解决方案公司（Special Solutions Inc.）的热线，这是一家位于伊利诺伊州德斯普兰斯的反监视公司，认为他们的地方被窃听了。这时马克·阿梅拉西安就会采取行动，准备好他的装备。
Let's see, we have sweep units here, which will pick up any type of microphones. Night vision, parabolic microphones--
让我看看，我们这儿有扫描装置，可以拾取任何类型的麦克风。夜视仪、抛物线麦克风——
Mark Amerazian is a counter-spy, and he dresses the part. Black T-shirt, boots, and a bomber jacket. His hair is slicked back, and he has a goatee. He talks and acts like someone playing a cop on TV, everything's just a little too polished. Mark has promised to take me with him on a sweep to debug someone's house.
马克·阿梅拉西安是一位反间谍，他的着装也很专业。黑色T恤、靴子，还有一件飞行员夹克。他的头发往后梳得油亮，留着山羊胡。他的言谈举止就像是在电视上演警察的人，一切都显得有点太完美了。马克答应带我去对某人的房子进行清扫。
He works out of a retail store called Spy Source, which is next door to a dry cleaners in the suburbs. There's a mannequin at the door wearing a trench coat, hat, and sunglasses, James Bond posters everywhere, a half-dozen glass display cases packed with electronics, and novelty items like X-ray specs and disappearing ink. One of the first things I notice is that what they sell at a counter-surveillance store looks a lot like the stuff they sell at a surveillance store. He points out a display case full of what seem to be everyday objects.
他在一家叫“间谍源”的零售店工作，那家店就在郊区一家干洗店隔壁。门口有一个穿着风衣、戴着帽子和太阳镜的人体模特，到处都是詹姆斯·邦德的海报，半打玻璃陈列柜里装满了电子产品，还有像X光透视镜和消失墨水这样的新奇玩意儿。我注意到的第一件事是，他们在反监视商店卖的东西，看起来和他们在监视商店卖的东西很像。他指着一个装满日常物品的展示柜。
Covert cameras are usually-- like this one's a clock. Here's a dictionary that has a camera in it. Teddy bear.
隐蔽摄像头通常是——比如这个是时钟。这有一本字典，里面有个摄像头。泰迪熊。
Where's the camera?
摄像头在哪儿？
You're not going to be able to see it.
你是看不出来的。
Mark says these kinds of cameras, with lenses literally the size of a pinhole, hidden in everyday objects are exactly what we'll be looking for on our sweep. So he shows me a tool that his company has designed to detect them, the SpyFinder. Mark pulls the consumer model out of his pocket, the SpyFinder Personal. It's made of black plastic like a remote control and contoured to fit in your hand, with a red plastic lens that you look through surrounded by flashing infrared light.
马克说这些摄像头，镜头大得只有针孔那么大，藏在日常物品里，正是我们在清扫中要寻找的目标。所以他给我看了一个他公司设计的用来探测它们的工具：间谍探测器（SpyFinder）。马克从口袋里拿出消费级型号，间谍探测器个人版。它由黑色塑料制成，像遥控器一样贴合手掌，红色的塑料透镜让你透过它看，周围闪烁着红外光。
What it's going to do is it's going to flash out, and if there's a camera there, it's going to detect that pinhole lens, the chip inside, and bounce back a red light at you. So if you want, I'll hold this microphone for you, and then just take this, press that button, look through it. So right now let's look at the clock.
它要做的是发出闪光，如果那里有摄像头，它会探测到针孔镜头、里面的芯片，并反射出红光给你。如果你愿意，我可以替你拿着这个麦克风，然后你拿着这个，按那个按钮，透过它看。现在让我们看看那个时钟。
I turn to the store clock hanging on the wall.
我转过身看向挂在墙上的店钟。
Scan the clock up and down. Where do you see the camera in there? Do you see it?
上下扫描一下时钟。你看到里面的摄像头了吗？你看到了吗？
Oh, I see it. There it is in the six.
哦，我看到了。它在数字6那里。
It's in the six.
它在6那里。
I flash the SpyFinder around the rest of the room. The whole place lights up. Everything's a camera. The smoke alarm, the plant, a pair of sunglasses, a radio. They're all watching. It can make a person paranoid, a paranoia that Mark is only too happy to indulge. He tells me a story of a hidden camera that was found in a Hooters changing room. He says they can be anywhere. Locker rooms, tanning salons.
我把间谍探测器在房间的其他地方扫了一遍。整个地方都亮了起来。每一样东西都是摄像头。烟雾报警器、植物、一副太阳镜、一台收音机。它们都在看着。这会让一个人变得偏执，马克很乐意放纵这种偏执。他给我讲了一个在“猫头鹰”餐厅试衣间发现隐藏摄像头的故事。他说它们可能出现在任何地方。更衣室、美黑沙龙。
A lot of people fake and bake. If you're faking and baking, why not have a SpyFinder with you before you're actually taking off your clothes and getting into a tanning booth? Do a quick sweep. See if there's a camera watching.
很多人去美黑。如果你去美黑，为什么不在脱衣服进入美黑舱之前随身带个间谍探测器呢？做一个快速扫描。看看是否有摄像头在监视。
I just came-- come on in, I'm sorry about the leaves.
我刚到——请进，抱歉这些树叶。
No--
没事——
Today we're doing a sweep for a woman who feels that someone's bugged her house. She greets us at the door in a velour jogging suit. I had expected anybody needing counter-surveillance would be somebody with money, and Mark had described his clients as corporate execs and semi-celebrities, or people in the middle of a high-stakes divorce or lawsuit. But we're at a squat brick bungalow behind a bowling alley and a fast food chicken joint. Her house is sparsely furnished. It's just her and her 6-year-old granddaughter.
今天我们为一个觉得有人监听了她家的女人做清扫。她在门口迎接我们，穿着天鹅绒慢跑套装。我本以为需要反监视的人会是有钱人，马克曾把他的客户描述为企业高管和半个名人，或者正处于高风险离婚或诉讼中的人。但我们是在保龄球馆和快餐炸鸡店后面的一栋低矮砖房。她的房子家具稀少。只有她和她6岁的孙女。
She immediately asks me if I'm recording her. She won't tell me her name or why we're here. Mark starts putting his gear on, headphones, a hand-held meter, and a few antennas he points around the living room. If there were an audio transmitter in the room, a listening device, it'd have to give off a signal.
她立刻问我是否在录音。她不告诉我她的名字，也不说为什么我们在这里。马克开始穿戴他的装备，耳机、手持仪表，还有几根天线，他在客厅四处指点。如果房间里有音频发射器、监听设备，它必须发出信号。
Right now we're not getting any type of signals showing me RF radio frequency being transmitted. So so far so good.
现在我们没有收到任何显示正在传输射频信号的信号。所以目前为止一切顺利。
Then he plugs a voltage meter into the phone line.
然后他把电压表插到电话线上。
It's reading a 44.7. This is a normal voltage reading. If there was something on your telephone line like a recorder, or if there was a tap on your outside line, it would be reading something low, like maybe a 20. So this is fine.
读数是44.7。这是一个正常的电压读数。如果电话线上有像录音机之类的东西，或者外线被窃听了，读数会很低，可能在20左右。所以这个是正常的。
The woman follows Mark around while he does the sweep. He looks in vents for cameras, and climbs under a desk to check the wiring on the computer.
马克在进行清扫时，那个女人一直跟着他。他在通风口找摄像头，爬到书桌底下检查电脑上的接线。
There's a unit that you can attach to the back of these computer keyboards, and whatever gets typed, it's going to record it.
有一个装置可以附在这些电脑键盘后面，无论输入什么，它都会记录下来。
You what?
你说什么？
I never thought of that.
我从没想过那个。
Something being on the computer?
电脑上有东西？
Yeah, I never thought of that.
对，我从没想过那个。
You looked startled when he said that.
他说那话时你看起来很惊讶。
I was. I was. I should have thought of that, and I never did.
我是。我是。我本该想到的，但我从来没想过。
I can't get much out of her, and what she does tell me doesn't really add up. She tells me her suspicions started a few months ago. She said a guy came to the house claiming to be from the water company. She thinks he may have planted some sort of eavesdropping device. When I ask her who she thinks he really was, and why he wanted to spy on her, she won't tell me. All she says is some things were done that made her uncomfortable, and she wants to put her fears to rest. In all, the sweep takes Mark about 20 minutes. He doesn't find anything, which is how it goes for him nine times out of ten.
我从她那儿问不出什么，她告诉我的情况也对不上号。她告诉我她的怀疑始于几个月前。她说有个家伙来到家里，声称是自来水公司的。她认为他可能安装了某种窃听装置。当我问她她认为他到底是谁，为什么要监视她时，她不肯说。她只说做了一些事让她很不舒服，她想消除她的恐惧。总之，马克花了大约20分钟进行清扫。他什么也没发现，他十次里有九次都是这样。
Everything gave us a negative reading. There's nothing here.
一切都显示为负面读数。这里什么都没有。
Thank you very much. I feel much better.
非常感谢。我感觉好多了。
So you feel a lot better?
所以你感觉好多了？
I do. I do. Don't have to whisper anymore.
是的。是的。不用再小声说话了。
If you go into somebody's home or office, and they say, gee, I think my phone's tapped, and you check the phone, and there's no tap, that doesn't mean there wasn't a problem.
如果你去某人的家或办公室，他们说，哎呀，我想我的电话被窃听了，你检查了电话，没有窃听，那并不意味着没有问题。
Kevin Murray has run Murray Associates, an eavesdropping detection and counter-espionage firm, for over 30 years. If Mark is a suburban beat cop, Kevin is the director of the FBI. He deals with Fortune 100 companies, and he thinks what Mark and I did was kind of half-assed.
凯文·默里经营默里联合公司，一家窃听检测和反间谍公司，已经超过30年了。如果马克是郊区的巡警，那凯文就是联邦调查局局长。他处理的是财富100强公司，他认为我和马克做的事有点业余。
It's not what they show on TV. It's not the guy with the box and an antenna that comes in and wanders around the room wearing headphones and magically finds things, because most of the time it isn't electronic. There are much easier ways to get information.
那不是电视上播的那样。那不是拿着盒子和天线的人进来，戴着耳机在房间里游荡，神奇地找到东西，因为大多数时候它不是电子的。有更容易的方法来获取信息。
For instance, Kevin says most spies just dig through your trash, or make friends with your sister-in-law or your hairdresser. Bugging can be really expensive and difficult. Plus, here's something you never think about, you constantly have to go back and change the battery. Which is why most large-scale bugging operations only happen in the corporate world.
例如，凯文说大多数间谍只是翻你的垃圾，或者和你小姨子或理发师做朋友。窃听可能非常昂贵且困难。此外，这是你从未想过的东西，你必须不断地回去更换电池。这就是为什么大多数大规模窃听行动只发生在企业界。
Kevin once caught an international corporate spy in the act. He was transmitting secrets at a big company. On another job, Kevin found a hidden camera above an employee's desk. Turns out the guy's coworker, who was competing with him for a promotion, was watching him make personal calls to his girlfriend and reporting each and every one of them-- date, time, and length-- to the boss. Occasionally Kevin himself becomes a player in the corporate schemes he's uncovering.
凯文曾亲手抓获一名国际企业间谍。他正在一家大公司传输秘密。在另一项工作中，凯文在一名员工的办公桌上方发现了一个隐藏摄像头。结果那家伙的同事，那个正和他竞争晋升机会的人，正在盯着他给女朋友打私人电话，并报告了每一个电话——日期、时间和时长——给老板。有时凯文自己也成了他正在揭露的那些企业阴谋中的一员。
We were brought into a company, and the president of the company says, "I want you to check these offices." He points us over there. He didn't say he suspected anything. We were just doing this just proactively, just to make sure. It's good policy. It's good security practice.
我们被带到一家公司，公司总裁说：“我想让你检查这些办公室。”他指着那边。他说他没怀疑什么。我们只是主动做这件事，只是为了确保安全。这是好策略。这是好的安全实践。
So we get in there, and we start working. The next thing you know, we're up above the ceiling in the conference room, and we find this wire. Can't quite identify it right away, so we follow it out, and lo and behold it goes across the hallway in one direction over to the president's office, and is laying on top of his ceiling with a microphone. I say, great, what a great find. Well we get on the wire again and follow it backwards across the hall, through the conference room, across another hall, and into another executive's office. And we look at it, think uh-huh, OK.
所以我们进去了，开始工作。接下来你知道，我们到了会议室天花板上面，发现了这根线。一开始辨认不出它，所以我们顺着它往外走，顺藤摸瓜，它穿过走廊朝一个方向一直延伸到总裁办公室，躺在他的天花板上，连着一个麦克风。我说，太棒了，好发现。好吧，我们又沿着线往回走，穿过走廊，穿过会议室，穿过另一条走廊，进入了另一位高管的办公室。我们看着它，心想：嗯哼，好吧。
On the surface it looks like one of the executives is bugging the president's office. But on close inspection, it's not hooked up the right way. It can't work. This is a setup. It posed a real ethical dilemma to us, because it appears that the president is looking for a rubber stamp way of firing an executive, and it's not true.
表面上看，好像是其中一位高管在窃听总裁的办公室。但仔细检查后，它没有正确连接。它根本无法工作。这是一个局。这给我们带来了真正的道德困境，因为看起来总裁是在寻找开除一名高管的合法借口，而事实并非如此。
So what'd you do?
那你做了什么？
We reported it to him, and we also reported the fact that we didn't think it was a viable eavesdropping attempt. This thing couldn't work.
我们向他汇报了，我们也汇报了我们认为这不是一次有效的窃听企图。这东西根本没用。
But he probably fired him anyway.
但他大概还是把他开除了吧。
And from our point of view, it's put there to look like an eavesdropping attempt.
从我们的角度来看，它是为了看起来像一次窃听企图而安装的。
By you.
被你？
No, I didn't say "by you," because I don't know who put it there. I didn't have enough proof. But I could tell he had kind of a long face, and said, "OK, thank you, boys."
不，我没说“被你”，因为我不知道是谁放的。我没有足够的证据。但我能看出他拉长了脸，说：“好吧，谢谢你们，小伙子们。”
I asked Kevin if stories of hidden cameras everywhere, like the ones Mark kept telling me when we are on the sweep, if those are just paranoia, or maybe a guy is just trying to drum up a little counter-surveillance business. I mean really, with everything we're supposed to be afraid of when we go to the tanner, bacteria, blindness, cancer, should we really worry about peeping toms?
我问凯文，那些关于到处都有隐藏摄像头的传言，比如我们在清扫时马克一直对我说的那些，是偏执狂，还是有人只是在试图通过反监视业务赚点钱。我是说真的，当我们去美黑时，那些我们要担心的东西——细菌、失明、癌症，我们真的应该担心偷窥狂吗？
Absolutely.
绝对应该。
Really?
真的吗？
Absolutely.
绝对应该。
No.
不。
All I can say is I don't make it up. Just go to SpyBusters.com, and every week or so I throw in all the news stories of peeping tom cameras and everything else. I think I have about six or seven years' worth of news stories there. And these are only, remember now, these are the failed attempts. These are the ones that got caught. It's the tip of the iceberg.
我只能说我不是瞎编的。去SpyBusters.com看看，每隔一周我都会把所有的偷窥狂摄像头新闻故事和其他东西发上去。我想我有大约六七年的新闻故事在那里。而且要记住，这些还只是失败的尝试。这些是被抓到的。这只是冰山一角。
Kevin says only one out of five calls he gets is from someone who's just being irrational and paranoid. In his experience, if you think you're being spied on, you probably are, or at least something's amiss. Maybe your boyfriend's going through your purse. Maybe your best friend's a gossip, and that's why other people know your business. But you don't need to hire a spy to figure that out.
凯文说他接到的电话里只有五分之一是来自那些仅仅是无理取闹和偏执的人。根据他的经验，如果你觉得你在被监视，你很可能确实是在被监视，或者至少有些事情不太对劲。也许是你男朋友在翻你的钱包。也许你最好的朋友是个长舌妇，这就是为什么别人知道你的事。但你不需要雇佣间谍来搞清楚那个。
Jane Feltes is a producer on our program.
简·费尔特斯是我们节目的制作人。
Well our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Ms. Amy O'Leary. Special thanks today to Patrick Keefe, Shane DuBow, Carrie Miller.
我们今天的节目由黛安·库克和我本人，以及亚历克斯·布伦伯格、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格和丽莎·波拉克共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和艾米·奥利里女士协助制作。今天特别感谢帕特里克·基夫、谢恩·杜博、卡丽·米勒。
OUR WEBSITE: www.ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download audio of our program at Audible.com/ThisAmericanLife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times, all at Audible.com.
我们的网站：www.ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买光盘。或者你知道，你可以在Audible.com/ThisAmericanLife下载我们的节目音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在Audible.com。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, or as he likes to be called by the many, many guests to our program, "The Cooler."
WBEZ对我们节目的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，或者像他经常被我们节目的许多来宾所称呼的那样，“冷柜”。
I'm not really sure what he wants me to do. Did he just say, "Touch the cooler?"
我不太确定他想让我做什么。他刚才说的是“摸那个冷柜”吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
PRI: Public Radio International.
PRI：公共广播国际公司。